[Music]
I got a war for you you know that
against this whole city but they're not
breaking us up this time
I thought she moved to another shelter
now you know I was in Rutgers I really
missed you girl yeah and apparently
these rules
[Music]
every just let me see your eyes so I
know you're not mad at me I'm staying
out of trouble this time
[Music]
tell me more about your Foster mother
you like her
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
you're a blessing
for your mom especially
you getting older now time for you to
start thinking for yourself
Daryl's a very bright kid have you
thought about MIT Harvard
[Music]
is your mother home maybe it's time to
give him something answers that he'd
been looking for is Daryl your real name
have you told anyone else about this no
it was good
when are you going to realize that you
are enough
[Music]
I'll go to war for you you know that
against anybody
against this whole city but they're not
breaking us up this time
[Music]
you normally needed you